[Musique]
la revue de presse avec vous hélène
frade rebonjour hélène bonjour pauline
on revient à présent à nouveau sur les
réactions aux coups d'état au burkina
faso où les militaires on l'a vu au
début de ce journal ont destitué le
président cabouret outre le cocktail
explosif des querelles incessantes entre
politiciens et de la capacité des
dirigeants à assurer la sécurité ou à 4
c ra explique aussi ce coup d'état par
un effet de contagion venu du mali
voisin alors qu'on vient de le dire la
coupe d'afrique des nations bat son
plein le site burkinabè file la
métaphore footballistique
après un dribble diabolique qui a
désarçonné la défense malienne le
colonel assimile gaza goïta a adressé
une courte passe au colonel guinée à
mamadou doumbouya qui à faire long
centre vers le colonel burkinabè
polhenri sandaogo damiba le nouvel homme
fort du burkina qui d'une tête imparable
a cloué au pilori le gardien de but
roch marc christian kaboré quels
lendemains pour le burkina faso le pays
espère que la situation n'expose pas sa
population à de lourdes sanctions
internationales à l'image de ce qui se
passe avec le mali estime qu'il est
temps pour les africains de revoir de
fond en comble leur système électoral
pour qu'au delà de la légalité des urnes
les présidents élus et la légitimité
nécessaire pour être à l'abri des coups
d'état après le mali la guinée le
burkina à kiel tour s'interroge le jelly
d'après le site d'info guinéen l'afrique
de l'ouest forêt actuellement les frais
de la décadence éthique de ses
dirigeants selon lui deux d'entre eux
illustrerait particulièrement ce recul
préjudiciable l'ancien président guinéen
alpha condé et l'actuel président et
varela alassane ouattara deux anciens
opposants qui ont fait le choix avec une
arrogance assumé je cite de s'offrir des
troisième mandat en voyante un très
mauvais signal l'ensemble de l'afrique
de l'ouest le jelly décrite ainsi le
dirigeant type de la région
d'aujourd'hui aucune empathie mais un
mépris érigé en comportement d'où la
désinvolture avec laquelle certains
d'entre eux ont abordé la dégradation de
la situation sécuritaire au sahel rien
d'étonnant donc si partout on célèbre
leur chute rien d'étonnant que partout
l'armée veille exploiter ce fossé entre
les dirigeants et les populations ce qui
s'est passé au mali en guinée et au
burkina faso risque de se produire
prochainement à niamey à abidjan à
cotonou ou même à dakar au fait tease le
site qui évoque lui aussi un effet de
contagion dans un contexte où la france
dé perçue comme la complice du diable
est justement qu'est-ce qu'elles sont
les réactions ici en france mais
l'afrique de l'ouest serait-elle en
train d'inventer un nouveau concept
celui de coup d'état militaire populaire
écrit libération d'après le journal les
scandales de corruption comme
l'incapacité à freiner les jihadistes
ont fini par décrédibiliser le pouvoir
civil dans la région la tentative d'état
aux koulaks ou tentative de coup d'état
au burkina menace l'avenir de
l'opération barkan et risque de porter
un coup fatal à l'engagement militaire
des européens dans la sous région la
croix parle d'un scénario catastrophe
pour la france qui considère le sahel
comme capitale pour sa sécurité et celle
de l'ensemble de l'europe sa démission
sur un tout autre sujet est elle
inéluctable royaume-uni boris johnson ne
se dépêtre décidément pas du parti ghad
un autre jour une autre fête annonce un
brin désabusé de daily mirror dernier
épisode en date de ce parti gate la
participation du premier ministre à une
fête d'anniversaire organisée en son
honneur au 10 downing street la
meilleure discothèque de l'ong indique
indubitablement le gâteau qu'on va aller
le nom n'est pas celui de la petite
sauterie à laquelle trente convives ont
participé le 19 juin 2000 va en plein
confinement une belle tranche
d'hypocrisie s'étrangle le tabloïd non
boris tu ne peux pas avoir le beurre et
l'argent du beurre de sun rapporte que
l'entourage du premier ministre a tenté
de le défendre une nouvelle fois en
précisant ce coup-ci qu'il était resté
que dix minutes la soirée voilà changé
et qu'il n'avait pas souffler sur les
bougies merci beaucoup et lan une image
hélène pour vous donc vous êtes fait
l'écho il me semble ces dernières heures
une image qu'on n'aurait pas pu voir il
ya quelques jours des spectateurs de
l'open d'australie le tournoi de tennis
australien à melbourne bien sûr t-shirt
web feng shui sur le dos était interdite
jusqu'ici c'est autorisé à présent à
condition d'être faits de façon
pacifique a dit le patron de l'open l
absence du tournoi de l'ex numéro un
mondial de double n'a pas levé les
inquiétudes sur la sécurité de panjwai
après qu'elle a dénoncé il ya quelques
mois le viol dont elle a été victime de
la part d'un haut responsable chinois
voilà t-shirt autorisée il est bien sûr
bien plus question qu'une affaire de
chiffons voilà pour cette image hélène a
très vite nous on se retrouve très vite
aussi sur l'antenne de france 24